although it has slipped up a couple of
times throughout the history of our
Solar System Jupiter has been protecting
us as millions of asteroids have been
heading towards Earth Jupiter's
gravitational pull has grabbed the
asteroids this puts them in Jupiter's
orbit and unable to reach Earth without
our giant protector Earth would be hit
by a lot more asteroids and it's
unlikely that another planet would step
in to fill Jupiter's Place considering
that the gas giant is the only planet
big enough to attract all these
asteroids this means Earth would get hit
by thousands more asteroids than it ever
has before some would be small and could
maybe help Earth bringing us new
elements but it's possible Earth would
get hit by a couple of big ones enough
to destroy anything that would be
evolving on the planet and maybe enough
to destroy Earth itself